[Musique]
comment savez-vous que ça va marcher il
m'acceptera et euh parce que nous payons
elle ne se souviendra peut-être même pas que vous n'avez
pas de mémoire d'alzheimer
quels sont ses passe-temps il aime boire
beaucoup vous voulez jouer à un jeu si je  te montrer
ma saucisse tu dois enlever ton pantalon
Bien sûr, j'ai appelé la résidence pour personnes
âgées et ils l'ont confirmé,
comment ne pourrait-il pas me dire s'ils
vous traitent bien,
ils ne vous énervent pas vraiment,
je suppose que vous êtes sur le même bateau,
nous sommes certainement tous les mêmes couches
[  Applaudissements]
il l'emmenait dans les clubs de jazz
du village il l'emmenait dans de
bons restaurants
[Musique]
je te la rappelle c'est exactement pour ça que
je t'aimais encore
vraiment c'était à propos du frère
ça doit être proche je ne le fais pas  pense que je te connais
[Musique]
toi